nous pouvons auprès de semer en dhr
monsieur le film aura avez-vous vraiment
l'impression de vous trouver justement
dans les langues
il ya trois quatre ans je n'aurais
certainement pas eu cette impression
c'est maintenant que je m'occupe le seul
musée de marquez
je sais que je suis l'une donne un des
paysages les plus intéressants elle
n'écrit particulier des landes
je suis persuadé que la plupart des gens
qui traverse ce pays se figure qu'il est
couvert de pain que son défunt qui
défilent et vient ce n'est pas du tout
cas là nous sommes le long d'une eu un
petit ruisseau qui est un affluent de la
leyre et qui est dans le coeur de la
lande et qui est adossé un serial à ce
musée que nous sommes en train de faire
c'est un musée comme vous voyez très
particulier puisqu'il se trouve dans la
nature
et il a quelque chose de tout à fait
particulier c'est que il allie les
sciences de l'homme et de la nature
c'est véritablement la science de
l'environnement qu'on est en train de
montrer environnement de l'homme landais
l'homme landais s'est installé dans ce
pays et pour vivre il a été obligé
d'utiliser les éléments de la nature des
éléments de la nature sur les plantes de
la lande
comment est ce qui va les transformer il
va les transformer à l'aide de moutons
c'est le mouton qui va goûter ses plans
de la lande et qui va faire le fumier
qui finalement leur permettra permettra
aux habitants des landes de faire les
cultures d'ogm
il ya là un mécanisme de jonction homme
nature la nature à porter éléments
l'homme apporte son intelligence et sa
technique et ensemble ils vont réussir à
apporter les éléments mais ça combiné
les éléments pour permettre aux
habitants de vivre et l'exposition qui
est installé dans les granges de serial
montre justement cette liaison intime
entre les choses de la nature et la vie
des hommes
c'est vraiment l'originalité de ses
présentations fap n appelait ça un musée
en tout cas c'est une formule tout à
fait moderne et nous parlerons
certainement pas de botanique une chose
comme ça non quand nous parlons des
plantes et bien nous parlons des plantes
que manger de moutons nous les montrons
nous parlons des plantes que qui servent
à fabriquer la litière ce sont encore
les plantes de la lande et ce musée se
termine par un à sentir centre
d'initiation à la nature qui replonge le
public de la façon la plus naturelle
dans la nature qui lui donne un
véritable contact avec elle et lui
permet d'en découvrir les principaux
éléments constitutifs
donc c est un peu une école à la
rousseau si vous voulez c'est un peu
débiles qu'on promène dans la nature et
je pense que à la fin de la visite
et bien les personnes un peu attentive
auront véritablement un contact avec la
nature des landes est que lorsqu elles
continueront leur voyage elle le
continuerons avec une certaine intimité
avec cette nature ce musée de plein air
de marquez situer aux environs de sabre
dans les landes est l'élément essentiel
du parc national régional qui en
aquitaine intéresse 24 communes tant
landesk girondine mais il s'agit encore
d'un chantier monsieur jean claude
bellot
le clou de ce musée de plein air de
marquer sur le plan des bâtiments c'est
bien cette maison il s'agit bien
effectivement de cette maison qui est
une maison traditionnelle maison
traditionnelle en date certainement un
des plus beaux spécimens
cette maison se trouvait à une
dizaine de kilomètres d'ici dans un
quartier appelé le mineur
cette maison a été entièrement démontées
après avoir été soigneusement numérotés
et cette maison a été reconstruite ici
en suivant les principes des musées
scandinave dans le domaine cette maison
actuellement est si on peut dire hors
d'eau en ce sens que le gros oeuvre au
point de vue charpente est maintenant
terminée il reste à carreler cette
maison est à construire le torchis c'est
dans cet état que nous présenterons aux
visiteurs ce bâtiment dans le cadre du
sentier d'initiation aux paysages
landais qui associe à la fois la nature
et le bâtiment d'habitation un cycle
bâtiments d'exploitation association en
sommes là aussi de l'homme et de la
nature
quand le public sera-t-il admis monsieur
bello a visité cet ensemble
le public sera convié à visiter cette
exposition à partir du samedi 1er août
pendant le mois d'août les visiteurs
auront accès à l'airial de marquèze du
mercredi au dimanche
pendant les mois de septembre et octobre
le samedi et le dimanche uniquement
l'accès se fait par train à partir de la
gare de sabre cet accès est le seul
autorisé à l'airial de marquèze
et c'est d'ailleurs un plaisir
supplémentaire puisque ce train est
constituée d'anciens dragons qui assurer
les liaisons autrefois en traversant
cette région très exactement le petit
train
qui allait effectivement de la gare de
sabre jusqu'à la boillat c'était le
petit train des résines